[Music]
hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me
so i wanted to talk to you guys a little
bit about a science fiction book that i
read at the beginning of this year
children of time
now i really do think that in the last
10 years or so we really have entered a
new golden age of science fiction now
you've got james essay corey with
the expanse series you've got six in
those three body problem series being
originally published in 2008 but then
republished in english in 2014 and then
you've got children of time which was
published in 2015
and then honestly a lot more i mean the
martian by andy weir was one of my
favorites but moving on from that
this book is very very good and reading
it it instantly
became another
modern favorite of mine now this book is
about a lot
it's about consciousness it's about what
is the self it's about evolution it's
about social issues
it's about the struggle for the survival
of humanity it's about the hubris of
humanity it's about war it's about
cruelty this book is about so much that
i can't really discuss it all in one
video
but i do want to talk about some
specific aspects of the book that i
really
really liked so keep in mind for those
of you that have not read the book there
will be some spoilers
in this video
so this book starts off at a point in
mankind's history where we have the
ability to terraform other worlds
now not everybody on earth is okay with
this some people feel like it's playing
god some people don't but there is
ongoing conflict
now you have a scientist named kern who
is leading this project and she intends
to release a barrel of monkeys onto this
newly terraformed planet along with a
virus that will speed up their
evolutionary process
from the beginning it's clear that kern
wants to become a god and she literally
thinks in the first chapter
this is the future this is where mankind
takes its next great step this is where
we become gods
so she intends to wait it out in sort of
a cryogenic situation until the monkeys
have evolved to the level where they're
humanoid and intelligent and then she'll
go down to that world and she would be
embraced by these humanoid monkeys
as a god
now i won't spoil every detail of this
but of course the plan goes horribly
wrong as it's pretty clear it's going to
go from the beginning adrian tchaikovsky
does nothing to indicate that this is
going to go well you pretty much know
from the beginning and the monkeys in
the barrel end up perishing
but the virus itself
does get down to this newly terraformed
world which has all sorts of other earth
animals on it
and that's where
porsche the spider comes in
so this book is essentially about a
man-made virus
increasing the speed of the evolution of
spiders
and they slowly become sentient slowly
build a civilization and slowly start
communicating with kern who for
the majority of the book believes these
to be her monkeys and kern herself has
her own situation going where she's
melded with the computer system inside
of the shuttle that she's been
hibernating in so the line between
kern's mind and the mind of whatever the
ship's computer has become have blurred
a lot and she's basically a lunatic
now over the hundreds and hundreds of
years that kern is hibernating while
this spider civilization is building
humanity has fallen into a state of
significant decline to where the
civilization has been nearly eradicated
the last remnants of humanity are on a
generational ship and it's not going
very well for them and it's interesting
because you get to see
the rise and decline of the culture and
the society on this generational ship as
various characters go in and out of
hibernation decades at a time often so
at one point in time things might be
stable and peaceful and at some other
time a dictator might have taken over
the entire ship and like enslaved
everyone and so this first book
constantly flips between what's up with
the last remnants of humanity and what's
going on with this building spider
civilization
and as the book goes on and on you're
realizing that where this is leading to
is that the last remnants of humanity
will have to face off against
kern's spider civilization which does
get pretty advanced and it was also very
interesting to see how exactly that
spider technology develops it's a lot of
biological technology i particularly
loved the idea of
ants being used to build an organic
computer it was just endlessly
fascinating and very very intriguing
so apart from all the incredibly cool
sci-fi ideas in this book and i haven't
even got to all of them there's so much
more it's just a really engrossing story
it's very engaging
an absolute page turner because you just
want to know how far does this go
how advanced will this spider
civilization become because evolution
doesn't necessarily have an end point
species continually adapt to their
environments and as their environments
change they have to develop new
adaptations but evolution
never ceases to continue and the other
really engrossing part of this book was
to see the formation and the evolution
of the extraordinarily complex
social and societal structure of the
spiders themselves so human behavior on
a mass scale i'm speaking in general is
informed by our biology because we are
descended from primates our society
formed
in a specific way now because the
society of arachnids in this book are
descended from spiders
their society develops in a very
specific way that's distinct from
humanity and actually kern has a very
difficult time
understanding them at all because though
they have developed intelligence it's a
different sort
of intelligence to the intelligence of a
human being and there's a lot of like
reconciling that you have to do to be
able to communicate effectively between
two species with entirely separate
evolutionary tracks spiders would not
evolve intelligence and then immediately
start thinking like humans
and feeling like humans they wouldn't
become humanoid they would still be
spiders
but intelligent spiders with intelligent
spider thoughts so children of time was
an absolute 10 out of 10 for me i love
this book and i'm definitely going to
discuss it more in the future thank you
guys so much for watching make sure you
like and subscribe for more quinn's
ideas peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you